what did you look you look younger
what'd you do you there's something with
your eyebrows did you do something with
your eyebrows
it looks young i did are we on or no are
we
we're not on yet thank god yeah so i'm
looking at you i'm like what is going on
you look like you're you know
10 years younger or something that's
good yeah well i also got laid this
weekend
you want to celebrate it whatever yeah i
don't care we can say your name i'll say
both of their names
all right we're live okay
all right so we are back today episode
number 35 adam is back from miami
obviously had a great time and thomas
back here from california nice to see
you guys
and uh it's it's good to uh we got a lot
of things to cover today a lot of crazy
stuff
yeah uh we've had some crazy stuff
happening here in the office we got
kai back from norway kai say hi to
everybody yeah
how was vacation in norway for you it
was nice i explored the fjords
shout out my boy adam laura's audio a
little bit it sounds like he's hollering
yeah lauren
go for it of god coming from norway no
so it was nice yes
saw the families of friends i was
texting with your mom and dad the entire
time you were there
first of all your family what did you
think about my library
i was sick yeah see i did see that so is
that really the boulevard named after
you in norway
all right so he's kidding with that part
so kai is means doc
okay sakai it's further down that road
got it
so in norway your dad and mom created a
library where others can borrow your
books and bring them back
yes that's a real story no
yeah you know it's a it's a it's a it's
it was like an abandoned bus stop so but
is it real that your books are there
where people can come in
my books are not all those books are all
this time i'm telling other people how
special of parents you got now this
he was playing us he was playing a joke
on me yeah and i told him it would never
work
let me tell you hey pops you played a
joke it worked and you got recognition
for it yeah but i'm taking it back
i'm taking it back anyways all right so
so welcome back kai
right yeah explore the fjords isn't that
what you did in south beach
yeah well i was exploring more than the
fjords well you look more relaxed you
look calm i'm glad you made that stop to
miami yeah yeah
i needed it maybe if we're in florida
what if that happens like
you're going to be more calmer what do
you think like i think i'll just be in
my comfort zone
that's what happens when he goes to you
know a red state man he could go down
there
floyd is a very purple state it's like
the it's like the joker's jacket over
there
that's so cool how was your uh christmas
new year i saw you for christmas
great we had a good time new years was
uh i couldn't even tell you what we did
what did we do for new year's did you
make it to midnight
new year's yeah i did i think you went
with mario
oh yeah you know i did i was i made it
past midnight but everybody went to
sleep ever
you know jen's like oh babe i'm like
babe i know babe she's you
i i'm just happy to know you're
everybody she's
like i'm not feeling she sounded drunk
she's no she's pregnant
yeah yeah i know pregnant so she goes to
sleep my dad stays up a little bit the
kids stay up latest and then uh i stayed
up a little bit with mario
you were here in dallas i was here in
dallas yeah we had a meeting we had a
meeting this sunday and monday was one
of the most epic
was it not one of the most sam what was
that meeting about the two days we had
in dallas here pretty legit meeting we
had those two days with php
last couple days yeah it was a
ridiculous meeting and then it ended up
last night
i mean we have to do what we do you know
there's always uh uh
festivities but there was a little too
many festivities to last night which
we'll talk offline
not online but anyways let's get into
the show and did you
i got a question for zenner let's not
leave you out tom
the people want to know did you make it
to midnight on new year's you know what
did you guys notice how bad the tv was
that night
they were nobody was watching
list of of entertainers it was so bad
usually the shows that ring in the new
year i saw guyana
anderson cooper have you done acid
before you got to try i don't know yeah
that was
uh andy uh cohen yeah yeah
they try to outdo each other every year
and it's just it's nauseating watching
those guys so did you do
acid on new years or no i'm trying to
think if i made it past midnight you
didn't make it to midnight buddy you
weren't thinking about it
so if you're asking us the question you
must have made it to like six o'clock
and broke into your own rule so what
happened to you new year's eve
oh dude i really weren't gonna go there
well then what would you do
i was out i was about i was in south
beach i was doing my thing i actually
went to bed
slightly early for um what time
like at four and so you were fully out i
was out yeah it was out i mean
and then my buddy was south beach happen
on new year's eve you know what
a lot of the curfews in place at
midnight typically they
they extended it to one o'clock yeah but
here's the thing with curfews you just
go to house parties
but like i was that dude still in a mask
at a house party and the girl was like
take your stupid mask off i was like oh
[ __ ] that's what's going on all right
so i went to bed around four my buddy
adrian that you've spoken to
yeah cool guy he has a two-bedroom
apartment in south beach i was staying
with him wakes me up i swear to god at
five in the morning he's like
get up bro get up i got two girls out
here wake up i'm like
what what i i i'm i'm
straight up piss drunk i got my glasses
on i wake up i'm like hey they
like completely confused i was like i'm
just going back to bed now that's good
so yeah so you went back to bed he went
back to investigations
yeah i made a new friend that night just
because okay good okay
all right sounds good sounds good all
right it was interesting so
but happy new years everybody yes so we
have a lot of different things to cover
here uh something
something very weird is going on with
jack mom very weird
very very weird yeah october 24th he
gives a speech which we'll talk about
and then he's disappeared since the
richest man in china has disappeared
after he made a few comments about g
and they haven't seen him since then
then he had roku
is getting near to a deal of buying
quibby which we talked about recently
when we did the video i said someone's
gonna buy these guys content
out tesla zooms past 700 billion dollars
on the market
um and michael bury from the movie big
short the real michael bury
real life michael burrie tweets
something and then he deletes it and
it's pretty epic what happens there and
we'll read that
bitcoin plummet 17 percent however jp
morgan chase
just made some prediction this morning
which will cover that amc plans to sell
125 million dollars of stock due to
coronal virus pandemic says sec filings
barstool's dave portnoy raises 16.8
million dollars for 59 small
businesses and counting phenomenal
phenomenal job to that guy man what he's
doing the attention he's bringing
and the reaction of all these guys how
excited they're getting obviously
georgia runoff is taking place
uh the adam's favorite president is
going to be having a meeting this week
january 6th in dci clinton you're going
or you're not bill clinton
you're going to trump's rally to where
you're going to go to trump's to spend
some time with him or no
trump's doing a rally he's doing is he
going just let me just say something
it's just for the audience you know what
they're like
fun little comments i have not been
paying attention to the news
at all over the last i've had a meeting
how long two weeks
two weeks detox i've been spending time
with family friends a little bit of
partying over new year's
completely you know nothing about what's
going on the only thing i do know what's
going on is this jack ma thing because
kai and i
talked about it yesterday all right so
but all this stuff i'm hearing are you
gonna go
and be with trump on on the six
obviously that's my guy of course i'm
gonna go steal that i'm gonna like that
kind of stuff i'm gonna steal that
election trump
promises wild protest in washington dc
on january 6
claims it's impossible he lost u.s
officials are considering giving people
two half doses of modernist cover 19
shot
to speed up roll out vaccine chief
salawi
says and then a bunch of other things
north korea requested covet
vaccine cases from the global group even
though they reported that now one person
got a cope and we got a few other
stories obviously we got a
hardcore did we get the champagne to
celebrate pelosi's victory
uh uh fourth term as a house she's 80
years old how did she
she's exactly 80 years everybody that
makes decisions in this country is 80.
so so anyways all right so let's go to
do we go into the jack ma story i i want
to i want to hang
on the jack ma story a little bit let's
talk about the michael berry tesla let's
talk about that and then we'll go into
the jack ma
okay so tesla zooms past 700 billion
dollars of market value after nearly
hitting 500 000 deliveries in 2020 they
missed it by what 450 cars
i believe to say exact they sold for
they moved 499
550 deliveries in 2020.
elon musk exceeds his product production
uh target you know he felt sure briefly
so proud of the tesla team for achieving
the major milestone musk tweeted at
the start of tesla i thought we had
optimistically a 10
chance of surviving at all tesla stock
prices soared by more than 740 percent
in 2020 a ton of stuff is being said
about tesla right now we know this
progress but i want to go to the michael
burrie tweet
michael murray of the big short confirms
he's shorting tesla back in september
berry tweeted about tesla's loft
evaluation and said the company relies
on regulatory credit sales
rather than auto sales to turn a profit
in december
bury confirmed on twitter that he is
also putting his money where his mouth
is
so uh on twitter at elon musk
yes i'm short tsla tesla
but some free advice for a good guy
seriously this is he's saying to elon
issue 20 to
25 to 50 of your shares at the current
ridiculous prize that's not delusion
you'd be cementing permanence and untold
optionality if there are buyers sell
that tesla
souffle burry tweeted tuesday night the
tweet was
deleted since musk's warnings the
souffle mentioned was a reference to
warning must
issued this week to tesla employees the
tesla stock price
will immediately get crushed like a
souffle under a sledgehammer
if tesla doesn't reach the profit for a
profitability wall street
has already priced into the stock and a
musk famously tweeted that tesla stock
price is too high my honest opinion back
in may of first
tesla stock price is roughly quadruple
seven months since that warning written
in december so what's going on over here
with tesla it's gonna crash this year
there's no way it won't i mean
he is the flavor of the month anything
you do about
elon musk right now is a big story yeah
you know okay
he thought the company had a chance of
going under now it's worth 700 billion
by the way it went up five percent
yesterday so what's that you're thinking
that's no big deal that's 35 billion
that it just went up yesterday i this is
the christian bale
character we're talking about in the
short right this guy knows what's up oh
he knows
oh my god i mean this guy's this guy's a
doctor he's a genius
i i like elon musk i like him as a pop
culture character yeah i think he's one
of the most genius
minds that we've ever created on this
planet what he's doing with spacex what
he's doing with the
the boring company drilling these huge
holes in big cities and
getting rid of traffic but this is
ridiculous and you don't have to have a
finance degree to realize this is
quicksand this is going to just
and here's the other thing what if it
did dissipate in value by 50
wouldn't that still be a win for a guy
who thought his company was going to go
under if it was only worth 350 billion
are you are you speculating are you
saying this year they could drop 50
i'm saying it very well could happen
especially with a democratic
house of representatives yeah president
who knows where we're going to be after
today
barring the results of georgia but this
is just fairy dust this is crazy you
throw
out these numbers they're not even real
he's a pop culture character
larger than life a genius but this
doesn't make sense for tesla
no way can they sustain this type of
value
yeah i'm seeing these we've talked about
elon musk isn't basically this entire
year i mean nobody's had he's the number
one business person of the year for
2020 according to fortune magazine his
fortune has literally
gone from what 30 billion to over a
hundred he's the second richest man
he's gone from like not even in the top
20 or barely in the top 20 to number one
yep um but just a couple of things you
know
you ever seen like the movie the big
lebowski yes when they're like i don't
think you can do this big lebowski
you're a loser the basket he's like
that's like your opinion man so that's
kind of where i'm at
with with tom over here i'm like that's
just like your opinion man
like i that's that's just the first
thing that came to mind so
um total g i mean
let's just look at the numbers unless
i'm interpreting this wrong and all by
speaking of
like your opinion man the the guy
michael bury i mean he's got a pretty
credible opinion but
again one opinion there's a lot of
people saying that you should tor short
tesla but the people who are riding the
wave are obviously making money
but here's the number i'm looking at
they said that their their
production target was 500 000 vehicles
and they hit that number
they said they were off by a couple
hundred cars but sometimes they
um they're slightly conservative with
their numbers so the numbers could vary
elon's got 300 in his garage
to get that number up but like how at
this point
how do you bet against elon musk
with everything that he's doing i
remember we had uh
in one of the first podcast pat do you
remember this we said
and this is when elon musk man was like
barely in the top 20 billionaires i mean
he wasn't
like where he is right now it's been a
you know amazing run he's got this year
and we said who would you
bet on who who's the number one yeah
stock elijah
bezos here and elon and i was like no
i'm going with i'm going with bezos he's
from miami miami guy but at this point
how do you bet against elon musk like
you said he's a pop culture icon but
yeah i agree with you on that
but he's also a freaking genius and he's
delivering well let me ask you this if
you're watching this right now thumbs up
thumbs up if tesla stock goes up this
could actually be a lot of thumbs down
thumbs down if you think tesla stock
could go down okay at this in 2021
will it go up or will it go down here's
a couple things to be thinking about
here's a couple things to be thinking
about
you mentioned biden okay you mentioned
it's going to be a democratic
administration etc etc does the left
lean pro gas or does the left lean pro
uh uh electrocard for sure green so so
perfect so that benefits
a tesla right of course number two
uh we had tom on last week when we were
talking about
ge not ge gm talking about the fact that
hey
everything about now is electric he
showed the website he showed all this
stuff and
you know added there i don't know what
the number was some 20 million cars that
they sold
you know a small minuscule percentage
was what
electric but they said by 2025 all of
cadillac's gonna be what
electric and then by 2030 they're pretty
much making cadillac in
all 100 electric car that's crazy for
general motors to be deciding to do
something like that right
okay what advantage does he have
here's the advantage that he has what's
zuck worth
god knows what the guy's worth facebook
what is it 100 million
what is the chances of somebody being
able to create the next facebook to beat
facebook
zero okay i don't know if it's zero but
it's point zero zero zero zero zero
closest thing to
zero which i'm with you where are you
okay so what is the chance of somebody
building an electric car and competing
i don't think it's zero no but but i
think it's higher than
you know maybe say five percent that you
can make something and compete
the automotive business kind of like the
bottling industry or like the
soda business like to compete with coke
and pepsi very difficult certain
industries to get in and compete with
right okay
i think the advantage he has is
he came and said this is the future
and he took the lead and he indirectly
with all the different
charging places he has nationwide in
different places in europe the guy's got
a
semi-monopoly going on where you have to
all reads low to test
lead to tesla is it battery is it
equipment
is it char somehow someway you got to go
through tesla
does that mean this thing's going to
grow the way it's grown right now i
don't know here's the other thing i will
add with how tes
with how he is last week we talked about
it tom
where tim cook announced his car apple
stock goes up 103 billion dollars in one
day just because he dropped the ward
car in there right and the icard
the icard so i think the guy's a
visionary i think the guys killed it
this year i have i have no idea how it's
going to be in 2021
but i think everything is on his side
including a bike
administration would be on his side yes
let me follow up with a question to you
because i know you you're kind of
on the short side of things are we
talking about 2021 are we talking for
the next decade as an example
because if it's 20 21 great question i
can see it you know going down
over the next 10 years i'm a huge
believer in electric cars and tesla and
everything that even you said gm is
doing clearly we're on the path to that
clearly so if it's one year you may be
right but 10 years
the bar's been raised to such a level
where what if it did go down 20 or 30
does that mean he's not a success he's
still a huge success that's the thing
but he will be judged on this stock
price i secretly don't think that he
wants the stock price this high
what what's it to benefit him there's a
couple other factors number one
production
how many of these cars can you
legitimately produce per year they have
to create
more factories 500 000 isn't that many
cars
and they pushed it to the limit with a
huge fourth quarter to get to that
number
apple's coming into the game so is china
china has
three electric car manufacturing
companies
they have 1.3 billion people which
surprisingly
tesla is moving strong into china
they're having success
in china but in my opinion i think it
all comes down to the battery
because when you think about apple when
you think about apple getting into the
computer game they have their own
systems right they had their own uh word
you know they have their own business
documents their own software
which put them ahead of the game of ibm
if they can sum whoever controls this
battery
because if you can get a universal
battery that works with multiple
different types of cars you don't just
have to have a tesla
tesla might be out priced for some
people especially when the traditional
car makers are getting into the game
and you get and you get a like a lower
model which there already are some but
it's unfair to elon musk this stock
price because it is going to go down
and people are going to think that he's
a failure because of it i don't think
they are though i don't think that's the
conversation i think the conversation
right now is the following
i he he's he's built
multiple companies and he's been
successful okay you know there are
certain people
that four of them kisses for them okay
there are certain
you get to a certain status in your life
where you earn saint status
same status that doesn't mean you if you
if you do like an o.j simpson 2000 yards
in a season you know you go out there
and become the
leading russian then you do something
that you did i'm sorry that same status
is gone
forever right but he's insane status
today he has to really screw
up and do something stupid in his
personal life to lose that you're giving
him
status oh he's not done at once no no
i'm sorry
there is no other elon musk in america
in the world today
there is no other musk in the world
you're taking musk over bezos back to
our first game
but three companies yes he's right right
i'm not i'm not putting any
anybody ahead of this guy here really
nobody uh i don't put anybody at him i
tell you i think bezos is enjoying life
more than elon musk is i think so i
think bezos is a happier individual than
musk is
musk's brain is going a million miles an
hour and it's tough to kind of enjoy
yourself at times right
when you're going like that but let me
make my point to you here's basic math
okay their top line revenue in 2020
the last number they have in september
they don't have all of it but in 2020
28.7 1.7 billion dollars their revenue
is up 15.38
their revenue is at 15.38 let me say
this one more time
their revenue is only up 15.38
year-over-year say 20 they're up okay by
the way they finish
2020 with their last report the revenue
is up only 20
but the value is up for x okay let me
say that one more time your revenue goes
up
20 but the value of the company is up
four times uh that might so what's off
that so
so all michael murray is saying is maybe
it's not the time right now to
long this thing maybe it's good to show
them maybe you come back on a couple
years from now
that's what he's saying michael's not a
lightweight so it's not like you know
you you take who a elon musk is and you
take a michael bury michael burr is
great at what he does for him to be able
to predict you know what was going to
happen with real estate market everybody
said this guy's out of his mind
go all these big names looked at him and
laughed at him and he ended up being
right and they made a movie about him
and guess what he's the one guy he hates
doing interviews
he turns on all interviews if you get an
interview with michael bury
you got lucky he doesn't like the camera
he doesn't like to talk
he doesn't he doesn't like the voice to
do a lot of energy just kind of wants to
be
by himself in an office so for him to
say that the data
validates michael bury is right the
numbers
prove michael bury is right for 2021.
why did he delete the tweet though
because he is a non-confrontational guy
he just doesn't want
limelight he doesn't want the spotlight
and it brought more than he thought you
don't know what
sometimes you're having a drink oh you
know you're not gonna tweet it you
should tweet it on youtube you don't
know what happened no one knows the
context
that's you and your buddy right yes
exactly yeah he's a genius when you
watch that movie it'd be interesting to
see what else he jumped on in the last
12 or 13 years
since the real estate market but i mean
this is kind of common sense there's
just no way it can sustain this i don't
think
math math is not on the long side math
is not on elon's side
but social capital is on elon's side the
world is banking on this guy period kai
uh so i think elon musk is one of the
few if not the only
to uh help create or co-found four
billion billion dollar
companies you have paypal tesla spacex
and soldiers that's like danielle
day-lewis i forgot that he was involved
in paypal
yeah that's like oh it's okay give me
the company again paypal tesla
spacex solar city oh solar city what's
solarcity
solar panel energy and he also has the
neurolink
neuralink oh he's just boring company
he's just getting started
he's just getting started there's not
another elon musk in the world why can't
i
follow a question why do you say that um
bezos is enjoying life more than musk
well it's the it's the you know uh the
worried genius
i don't see bezos as a worry genius i
just see bezos as an analytics guy
that's
extremely logical asperger's no emotion
i see that as bezos
is that what he has that that's where i
would categorize because gates was
categorized as that at one point
when you have asperger's you you don't
have emotions
so you're not offended you're not upset
you're just
very much so focused right but i think
bezos is enjoying life more than
musketeers it's like our boy ben shapiro
i think
i think musk is constantly over thinking
about the next thing you want you know
what's funny
is if you go back 20 years and you look
at pictures of
of bezos and musk they look older than
today
they look better now yeah yeah like they
were balding
dollars and the right to yeah doctors
will do that there's one more factor
with bezos he looks happier now because
of his
new girlfriend lauren sanchez i mean
he's a different man
because she is a a sexual beast that you
could just tell
damn tom i was at her 30th birthday
doing it for you all right
so you know but she's you can just tell
he's
invigorated by her presence and he's
enjoying life he's taking her all over
the world
he seems like a happier guy that's what
i you know and maybe some
other of these other things that he's
accomplished in life has slid down the
ladder a little bit more because
why not enjoy the wealth like i was
driving around beverly hills a few weeks
ago with a friend of mine he's like hey
there's bezos house hey there's another
one
he has houses all over the place
everywhere i mean you don't even know i
mean
why not enjoy it yeah you know at some
point he's going to have another 20
years to enjoy it
twice basis he's 56 no i think he's
going to be good
he's gonna he's gonna live a long time
yeah remember that you know what city
has the uh highest average life
expectancy in the world
what city in in the world you can't say
it i
i'm gonna say it's a european country if
you see me do the video you can't say it
i haven't seen anything okay so which
city
i'm gonna say it's uh zurich
okay what are you gonna say so random
two things are popping in my mind
somewhere in in greece with a
mediterranean diet or possibly
uh some place in japan it's interesting
how you say you because you went into
people like oh i'm just gonna have fun
and i'm you know i'm just gonna
you know dance and drink and party what
what city is the richest city in the
world with the
monaco monaco monaco's life is the
highest in the world 89 and a half years
the average person lives 89 and a half
yeah because they're all freaking
billionaires
the point is when you have money you get
the best health care because that's what
you do so yeah
i think he's going to be living a long
time but not if you eat those lobster
rolls bro that'll set you back
yeah so okay i mean look i'm banking on
elon i think we're all saying we're
banking on elon long term tesla
i don't know the math is not on their
side in 2022 it's funny though he's got
four other fallback companies if this
thing does take a dive at all
and he's got the tequila coming out yeah
so question for tom
how are you who's lauren sanchez why are
you at her 30th birthday
and why do you know that she's a
quote-unquote sexual beast i don't know
any of that
uh because it's like your opinion man my
friend was dating her so why was that
her 30th birthday
yeah it was interesting okay who is she
lauren sanchez that's jeff bezos
no i got that part but who is former
news anchor phoenix la
um you know extra so yeah good good girl
i mean cool
how did that happen with those two
basils they were neighbors
you know they they lived next to each
other in bedford 12 houses and she was
married to the guy that ran
a caa no william morris yeah the co-ceo
of william morris well shout out to
uh bezos's ex-wife mackenzie scott she
gives giving money well she's
now worth 60 billion yeah and she's
giving away billions and billions of
dollars during the pandemic yeah it's
like
so shout out to her i have a lot of
respect for that because
i mean i don't know if you guys feel the
same way like the whole ex-wife thing
they do nothing
sometimes and they just kind of like
live a life of luxury because they
married some rich dude
and they go shopping and they kind of
live there just pissed off three percent
of our office yeah yeah i'm sorry ladies
uh but you know they just kind of live
that rodeo jive lifestyle they go
shopping they you know
but to see this lady that's worth this
much is giving away her money and
and giving back i got a lot of respect
is there a strategy behind your
compliment
yeah mackenzie scott how are you
recruiting how are you doing
mackenzie's going to be imagine adam and
mackenzie scott
yeah i actually adam goes overnight from
being more 30 billion and then he's
giving us videos how to be a billionaire
you know what matt listen you got to
listen up here buddy there's a little
podcast thing you got going on
that's a business decision isn't it
we're buying itunes tomorrow you know
you can run a podcast i'm going to buy a
pot yes
she gave away 6 billion and she's still
probably worth 8 billion more than when
she started
this this might deviate from the topic a
little bit but it's going to stay you
know in miami
speaking of this i asked girls this
question oh
are you a diner no no not that i asked
girls i say ladies
question for you you have two options
would you rather
be with a wealthy wealthy
dude you never have to work again in
your life you're living the high life
you're living in a mansion
you're driving a you know whatever car
you want you got all the like
life is good but this dude is busted
he's gross he's fat he's sloppy he's
bald like the whole thing
right you know or you're living with
some dude
you're with a guy total you know
stud six-pack you know
macho man sexual you know the whole
thing
but he's broke his [ __ ] and he lives
with his parents who do you pick
and you see these girls brains like
but the guy's got the money and then
he's but this
they can't compute a lot of times and
then finally do you know what the most
common response is
i'll just take the rich guy [ __ ] it like
that's what they settle on
but if you ask all the guys in this room
would you be with a wealthy older sloppy
lady or a hot supermodel who's broke
what are you picking both both this guy
says you're obviously picking the hot
chick right
is it even a question tom might want the
old lady i don't know who are you
picking
i'm taking the hot chick obviously
what's the processing
the guys are obviously visual creatures
and we don't care what like
how often do you actually care what the
girl does
i disagree really i disagree who you're
going with
the old rich lady no i disagree what i
disagree with you is
a guy is a mentally is an earner and
provider
so to him he takes the responsibility of
being an earner and provider
correct and a a woman depending on what
her priorities in her life are looks at
it as i need
a someone that gives me protection
safety
responsibility security and the guy
that's good looking is probably going to
be smashing 10 other girls at the same
time as you so
you're sharing your guys so there is so
yeah so the guy of course you're going
to go with the yeah a 40 guy you're
going to go because i'm going to go work
i'm going to go make my money yes i want
to be with the hot girl i don't need you
to bring your bills you agree with me
except i think you ought to consider a
strategy with mckenzie
i think for you believe me i've got some
calls out to her okay thank you
mackenzie please return a call i think
you got to consider something like that
for you okay so so now that we have that
let's go to the bitcoin community
bitcoin is on fire it went from nothing
to 34 000 dropped
17 everybody panics it's down to 30
thousand dollars but jp morgan chase
just predicted
it's pretty crazy for jp morgan chase to
say this by the way jp morgan chase just
said
that bitcoin in 2021
could pass a hundred forty six thousand
dollars yeah
they said it could pass 146 thousand
dollars in 2021
thoughts on bitcoin someone said the
other day was it the guggenheim
uh they they gave an interview it's a
pretty public um
philanthropic investment type asset uh
financial firm and they said they
thought that bitcoin can go to
uh 500 000 in the next few years so this
kind of goes back to the tesla thing
there's a difference if you're investing
to all our investor friends out there
there's a difference between
day trading and decade trading right so
if you're who knows what's going to
happen to bitcoin like if you freaked
out in 2018 oh it's going down it's
going down
and the high was 20 000. now we're
talking about oh my god it might come
down from 30
000. the the big question is where will
tesla be in five to ten years where will
bitcoin be in five to ten years
long term if you're thinking you know
shorting and it's going to be short in
the next year or so whatever
who freaking knows that's not the point
of investing it's a long-term strategy
yeah that's
sort of the problem that people get in
is they try to time the market it's not
about
timing the market it's about time in the
market right so
i think for a few years people were not
trusting crypto not trusting
um bitcoin not trusting um
blockchain everything but clearly with
everyone coming out there you just said
jp morgan
you had who paypal you had visa you have
all these financial firms they're saying
yeah
we're we're in on this we're in so the
question is is there a chance that it
goes to zero or it goes to a hundred
thousand
what zero no that's my okay so that's my
question there's more of a likely of a
chance in the next few years it goes to
a hundred thousand to zero
i agree okay i don't disagree so yeah
that's what i'm thinking long term yeah
yep
i think if you like did adam's theory
where he
you know asked these girls randomly on
the streets in miami do you want a rich
guy or a
if you asked randomly it's not random
but i guess girls i know but yeah okay
don't you think 99.9 of people don't
know what the hell bitcoin is yeah
so i correct i think this is a this is a
game
for people that understand it they will
doctor this price however they
see fit for them and i think there's no
limit to how high it can get and
i just don't think anybody understands
it last week there was a pretty big
story because the first
professional athlete is having part of
his salary in bitcoin an offensive
lineman and i forgot who he plays for
now he used to play for seattle
which is fascinating now he is sponsored
by a bitcoin company so him
sending out tweets you know he's having
to do that and i i didn't really fully
understand
just how much he knew about it other
than he was promoting the company but
i think you're going to see a lot more
of this i think people that want to
act like they're a step ahead i just
don't think there's a full understanding
of the average american what bitcoin is
let me let me give you
just a different perspective on what
happened on december 31st with me
december 31st
i have a million things to do and i'm
trying to finish off my year but at the
same time i'm trying to get my dividends
paid out to all the investors okay
so i call chase i'm on the phone 30
minutes with chase on the phone their
phone system wasn't working first call
hangs up i call chase again it hangs up
i call chase it's seven times
after being on hold for 15 minutes chase
things up then i have different then i
start calling on three different phones
then i get my relationship manager then
i go then i go to chase directly then i
it the whole event took about four hours
of my day
i sent a tweet to chase chase responds
back i said it's your phone system down
not working i'm speaking with your
seventh rep now and your whole music
works but the rep speaks
they cut out our finance department has
had problems with your phones all day
they tried on three landlines and two
cell phones and nothing
one guy responds back to me and he says
if you have to ask permission
to use your money then it's not really
yours and he says
bitcoin can fix this right so he says
this and i sit and i'm like you know
what
the fact that it took four hours of my
day
that i have to go do all of this stuff
are you really patrick bet david
what the hell do i have to tell you if
i'm patrick david so i'm sitting like
you know what
if this eventually goes this way with
the process it's way too slow of a
process
in the process of business like what we
do what i cons
the reason why we invested into that
technology three and a half million
dollars that we
put time into the last two years is to
eliminate steps so you can accelerate a
process
if bitcoin can accelerate
multiple processes for people's lives
and find i think the challenge they've
had here's the challenge with bitcoin
the typical bitcoin investor that's
obsessed about bitcoin
who understands it is it fair to say
that they have to be brighter than an
average individual when it comes down to
math
they have to understand the technology
blockchain you have to understand what's
really going on
you can't sit there and explain it to
the average person the average person is
like
what are you talking about crypto well
you got a mind what the hell is mining
well mining is this and
you know the deeper you go people like
dude it's just too technical for me
versus a baseball card industry that's
blowing up right now and they're selling
shares of
baseball cards here's this baseball card
they printed a hundred thousand of them
only 20 of them have got a psa 10. this
is one of the 20 that we have
it's worth this much for you the
market's paying 180 grand what do you
want to pay for it
it's probably going to be a 500 000 card
in five years the math and the way you
explain a baseball card is what
very easy so somebody says okay cool
i'll buy the baseball card and i'll sit
on it because you look at it as what
you look at it as artwork you know i'm
going to buy it and i'm going to sit on
that artwork
bitcoin if they if they learn how to
explain the benefits of it to different
types of people business owners
the average investor the average buyer
the day-to-day person the person that's
insecure about their money being
automatic the person
that's older that's worried about money
and this credit card you know this i
don't want to use my credit card online
if they learn to do better marketing
with that i think the upset on bitcoin
can be very high because the direction
we're going right now
people don't trust the government people
don't trust politicians people don't
trust these people
money like crazy they don't trust them
so i think i think
timing is on their side and if they do
it right this could be a very
interesting direction we go to the next
five or ten years i just have a thought
process and
i'm kind of tying everything we
discussed with tesla
with bitcoin so you know again with my
whole interviews everything i do
i've interviewed a lot of people you
know when i doing my man on the street
stuff
and i i actually went to a bitcoin
convention and i
interviewed hundreds and hundreds of
people who have no
investments whatsoever no 401k plan no
ira no roth ira no access
to the traditional stock market no s p
500 index fund
nothing nothing nothing nothing but they
got a bitcoin account
yeah that's very dangerous that is very
dangerous that's like saying oh are you
a stock market investor yeah
where do you invest tesla that's it that
you just have one stock tesla
yeah i'm riding with elon very dangerous
so diversification so i've learned this
just
through my time just investing you know
you kind of have your
your your main entree for me that's an s
p 500 index fund cool i have a majority
of that but you also have little bonds
you have maybe have a little
gold maybe you have a little
cryptocurrency if you're a believer in
in and bitcoin and blockchain you know
rather than doing five ten percent maybe
you put
20 20 on bitcoin right yeah i've got
like i put five percent you know like
nothing crazy yeah i put in you know
three years ago like 40 grand holy crap
drinks on adam yeah i mean
so no it's gone up a little bit by then
sixth out no no no no no no no this was
that like 15
50. okay good yeah so no it's gone up a
little bit but
never in a million years would i put all
my money into bitcoin or
into any crypto or into tesla that's
ludicrous but that's the
that's what people are doing it's like
oh i'm investing in bitcoin let me give
you the flip side of it let me give you
the flip side of it let me give you the
flips out of it
as ludicrous as that is in the next
five ten years you're going to hear so
many people
that this thing if this thing goes to
half a million dollars there's going to
be so many accidental billionaires that
they're going to say
billion everyone's going to talk to them
like an expert but they did exactly what
you told them not to do
they did the i put everything in so what
i'm trying to say which they buy and
hold long term whatever they don't try
to
get in and get out if somebody is
playing the i don't care i'm going for
every i want it all or i'm nobody that
that's a strategy some people are taking
they're banking on bitcoin helping them
become millionaires billionaires
that's what they're banking on i i don't
think it's a
most uh uh uh uh uh
least stressful strategy but if this
thing goes in a direction it's gonna go
it could end up being a very big victory
for those risk versus rewards exactly
exactly so
so let's talk about jack mo i think it's
time brandon for us to talk about
jackpots a little weird what's been
happening with jack ma so
jack mom comes out and gives a speech on
october 24th which i think both
all of us have read or you know you you
read some of the commentary on what he
said
i'll kind of say a couple of the stuff
that he gave the speech on october 24th
he came up he says look i'm a
semi-retired man i'm just jack ma
you know i'm going to give a message to
you today you're either going to think
this is immature
incorrect or laughable but i'm just
going to give this message to you that's
how you kind of set the whole thing up
where it was kind of making him be safe
and then he got up and he started
talking he says look there's three
challenges that we're facing
uh today one is lack of financial system
that china doesn't have a financial
system because we built too fast number
two
innovation must come out of price and
number three
credit management okay and he goes and
talks about
credit management i want to read a
couple of these things that he said
which is pretty epic on how we explain
credit management
uh jack ma he goes up and uh in a part
of his speech he says
president xi once said success does not
have to come from me
i understand this phrase to be about a
sense of responsibility about taking
responsibility for the future for
tomorrow for the next generation
many of the world's problems today
including china's can be solved by
innovation
however for real innovation to happen no
one will show you the way and someone
should
someone must shoulder that
responsibility because
innovation is bound to make mistakes
watch this let me read that one more
time
president xi once said success does not
have to come from me
he says in his speech jack ma i
understand this phrase to be about a
sense of responsibility
it takes it's about taking
responsibility for it for the future for
tomorrow for next year and many of the
world's promises that including china
can be saw my innovation
however so if you just go president xi
says this i understand he's saying this
however for real innovation to happen no
one will show you the way and someone
must
shoulder the responsibility meaning
president xi
must shoulder the responsibility
because innovation is bound to make
mistakes but the question is not how to
how not to make mistakes but whether we
can perfect and correct them after
making
mistakes and persistently innovate to
make a risk-free innovation
is to stifle innovation to make
risk-free innovation is to start that's
such a powerful statement to make to
make
risk-free innovation is to stifle
innovation there is no risk free
innovation in the world
there is no such thing as as risk-free
innovation
oftentimes managing risk down to zero is
the biggest risk
that that phrase is so it's like we just
talked about it right now with bitcoin
yeah
oftentimes managing risk down to zero is
the biggest risk
another part of a speech i'll read these
two and i'm gonna turn it over to you
guys
he says today it's really difficult to
regulate ourselves
it's hard to conduct regulation
everywhere around the globe innovation
mainly comes from the marketplace
innovation comes from the grassroots
innovation comes from young people
regulatory challenges are getting bigger
and bigger in fact xi'an
which means supervision the first
character in the ward for regulation in
chinese and guan which is the words he
uses
means management the second character in
the word for regulation in chinese
are two different things supervision
means watching you as you develop and
paying attention to your development
management means intervening when there
is a problem
or when there is a foreseeable problem
we are very good at management
but our supervision ability is sorely
lacking and then the last one
is this the third point the essence of
finance is credit management we must
change the pawnshop mentality of today's
finance and rely on the development of
credit-based
system today's banks continue to have
pawn shop mentality
collaterals and warranties are pawnshops
this was very advanced once upon a time
without innovations like collaterals and
warranties there would be no today
there would be no today's financial
institution and the development of
chinese economy over the past 40 years
could not have continued he's been the
president and ceo i think of the chinese
entrepreneur club the chairman
and also the president of the xi jiang
general chamber of commerce that same he
said i talked to many entrepreneurs
china's pasha mentality is severe and it
also affects many entrepreneurs
especially entrepreneurs
who have collateralized all their assets
there are also some people who
unscrupulously
take out loans and constantly increase
their leverage taking on more debt
and he explains as i know borrow 100 000
you're afraid of the bank
if you borrow 10 million dollars both
you and the bank become a pit
bit panic but if you borrow a billion
dollars the bank is afraid of you
there's another habit banks just want to
lend money to the big companies because
they're safe they don't want to lend
money to the small business owners
this is not going to work right anyway
he gives this talk after giving this
21-minute speech
people haven't seen him in public since
and it's now been seven weeks
what do you think is going on over here
wow i'll jump in here this this is a
huge story this
is i think pay very close attention to
this world because this is a microcosm
of what's happening
um number one there's three options for
jack ma right now
he's in custody he's hiding or he's dead
those are literally i think the three
options
he's a very very smart individual to do
what he's done
in a socialist country in a communist
country to be able to build
the epitome of a capitalist company you
know
it's unbelievable he's worth 60 billion
dollars we we had this on the docket we
were maybe we were going to talk about
jack ma and the ipo
and in the holding company last week i'm
going
why is he throwing all this out there i
thought there was a shelf life there was
a ceiling
for how long he could get away with this
in china
he's just too much like a world-renowned
capitalist for china
so my opinion he's hiding okay
he was planning for this he knew he
knows what the chinese government is
capable of
and he's hiding i don't think you just
go get jack ma
and arrest him like some you know um
like uh
like a reporter whistleblower journalist
in hong kong or something right
okay so i think this is a huge deal i
think he's in hiding i mean come on he
hasn't been seen since october this is
the richest man in china
china 51 billion yeah you know what this
just opened this should opens
everybody's eyes to what china is
capable of
and and the fact that we aren't taking
them more serious for for
decades china has been a thorn in our
side a menace now they are
like a serious serious problem that is
getting cocky
they can get away with anything and if
their strategy was to eventually control
a political party in this country
control the media i mean they're getting
very very close to checking off a couple
boxes
they are strategic they are marching
towards an end game that only they know
and this is scary the fact that jack ma
can just disappear
my opinion is he's hiding he's got the
resources to do it he's planned for it
for years and he's somewhere on some
island that's what i think
now you brought up a couple key words uh
number one being control
so let's just paint a picture of who
this would be
in the united if you're not familiar
with jack ma this is the equivalent of
jeff bezos saying some bad things about
the us government about trump
very normal in america and it happens
every single day every day
if um tim cook said something about
uh trump it'd be like on the today's
news and gone the next day right
the rock says something about trump all
right we'd laugh and joke about it it's
gone
jack ma says a couple things about uh
the ccp and president xi
is missing for almost two months this is
what's
this is life in china and i actually
want to want to throw it to you to to
get your opinion on
the it's like uh it's socialism at the
at the government side but capitalism
and the working thing
but the thing that that tom brought up
and i kind of had some notes on is
this is about control with alibaba
and ant group and everything that he's
doing he has access to
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
people ultimately
more than a billion people potentially
who can go directly to his business that
he
ccp has no control over what he's able
to do and
i think what do you mean meaning he
clearly they do not like what he has to
say wait so ccp has no control over what
they can do to to him no no no they
don't like
that he has access to all these people
his company has access to all these
people
yeah with and and can can what
that's my question is like what is the
control comments
how it works tell me how it works
everything is if you bow down to the
regime
yes then you get what you get okay which
he has done clearly
for years one thing you do not do in
china is
calling out president xi right
you do not do that buddy and he crossed
the line okay
so so imagine so so go to the setting go
to the setting
so it's october 24th he's given a speech
speech ends
he walks off he gets text messages his
attorney calls him
his peers call him his attorney probably
told him don't give the speech did he
contact his attorney say read the speech
this is what i want to read an attorney
said don't do it you think he talked to
his attorney
maybe he didn't talk to his attorney did
he pull off a jerry maguire i'm just
going to go and give this speech
i don't know did he take anyone's advice
maybe he didn't take anyone's advice
if he did take someone's advice what
happened there say he didn't take
someone's advice he gives a speech
right afterwards what are people texting
him
what was that all about bro what were
you talking about then what else was he
happening
maybe the talking was he arrested right
on the spot yeah maybe maybe there were
people there saying here follow us
somebody wants to talk to you and
go there he's disappearing right maybe
right after he's like dude i gotta give
him his friend says you need to leave
asap get
on a private jet on leaves and go
somewhere else no one knows no one knows
what happened right now with a guy like
this by the way it's been nine weeks i
said seven weeks
it's been nine weeks it's been two
months yeah it's been two months
over two months since this happened no
one knows but here's a rule of thumb you
know the whole thing started with these
guys wanting to break apart the ant
group right you know this
it's too big you guys are too big we got
to find a way to
you know break this thing apart and et
cetera et cetera this guy's a rich guy
billionaire all this other stuff the ipo
all this mess that was being talked
about right here's how the chinese
regulators slam the brakes on the firms
would be record-breaking 37 billion ipo
wait we're not doing this right that's
that's kind of how this whole thing came
about
the calls he got right afterwards
dude if they come and get this guy and
they're sitting with them
here's what china's now dealing with if
he disappears
and they kill him what happens to china
go through all the situations
that's a that's a pr nightmare to for
china
are you kidding me that richest man kind
of ends up dead after
so talks trash so then go there pr
nightmare yes
so uh the ant group uh ipo was halted
after the speech right yeah that makes
sense of course yeah so
so so they kill him so nightmare what
what's the possibility of being killed
by the way
hi that he that that it happened yeah
oh so you think it's possible that he
got killed i i'm thinking it is possible
okay it's possible okay yeah
all right i think he's go go let me go
okay so but china has to process if they
do anything to this guy hey
how dare you talk about us this way this
is
what i think would happen they bring
them in
they say hey we've known for the last 20
years that you're going to have a lot of
influence in the country
so we've had 300 of your employees that
have been insiders reporting to ccp
and we have recordings of you of 7 000
hours and these are some of the things
that you've said
and they're going to play it for them
and then we know some of your habits and
what kind of girls you like and what
kind of discs you like and what kind of
that you like and what kind of this you
like
we want you to look at this packet okay
we
are going to train you to come out and
you are going to say
great things about china like you've
never said before for the rest of your
life because if you don't
you're going to lose this this this this
this this this that
do you commit to that of what do you
think is going to say
yes if jack comes out
and in the next six months 12 months you
see him speaking
very very highly about china that's what
took place
okay they got something on them by the
way it's not a china thing that's
everything every country same thing
what's happening in russia america
that's everywhere that's not about you
know
that that's nothing new so i'm not
putting that on china that's a tactic
that we use
for a very very long time when it comes
down to things like saying if you have
dirt on somebody you call them into a
room and yeah
this is a different kind of dirt this is
an internal manipulation you know trying
to go on the inside getting you
all this other stuff you think china
doesn't know that jack was a threat to
them because jack was pretty opiniated
and he's connected with america and he's
admired and loved and enamored and all
this others of course
they know that so i think china is smart
enough to not go there but at the same
time
do you think china gives a [ __ ] what the
rest of the world thinks
no do you think they really do i don't
think china does
and if you don't like that china no
cares what the rest of the world what do
you think china cares more about do you
think china cares more about their
system their values their principles
what they do than what you think about
how they handle your situation yes but
if you start questioning their system
that's when i think they get a little
hold up like the everything that
happened with dara mori in the nba are
you thinking the hong kong protest do
you think
china is the kind of player where this
is what happens let me give you a
scenario you know how a player screws up
and they come out and next thing they
say what
i just want to say on behalf of my
family i'm very disappointed in my
behavior this is not
something that i do i let down they're
not going to apologize
do you think that's china no no no china
is not going to china's going to say no
that's who we are yeah
this is our system period we don't
apologize for that and they don't want
you they don't want people
questioning it you do not do that to
china yeah yeah especially when you're
the richest man in china
and china's getting to the point too
like what other country can say anything
negative about them
what an african country a european
country they have influence everywhere
you think joe biden's gonna like call
them out on whatever has happened to
jack ma
two things do you think the chinese
government takes over his company number
one do they think
do you think they allow him to continue
to run it like he has been and number
two
do you think he's gotten too comfortable
i do i think when you
when you have a worldwide business like
that and you travel to the united states
you see how this is
i think he got a little comfortable i
think he lost grasp of just
what they can do to him in his home
country is it comfortable or cocky it's
a big difference
is it comfortable or cocky i'm gonna say
comfortable okay because i think he's
got enough of an
edge where he wouldn't allow himself to
get cocky to be able to build that
business out of a one-bedroom apartment
like he did
so i think it's comfort as opposed to
cocky because i don't think you can get
that cocky in china
because there's constant reminders that
we will squash you so i think it's just
a level of comfort private jet g5 to the
us
you know to monaco to the south of
france wherever you want to go
and you forget this is where i'm from
these guys really do have their thumb
on me and they can press me down at any
time pat
you know what i think would be uh
helpful for i mean
i i'd like to know and maybe our viewers
would like to know because i know you've
done a lot of
interviews regarding china obviously um
general spalding and
everything with that how does the system
actually work with the
communist ccp you know socialist agenda
like don't question it versus yeah we
allow capitalism to happen on the
uh on the ground so to speak how do they
have that balance
how does that work it's capitalism with
respecting
the top okay you cannot question the top
you cannot say hey you're not doing this
right you're not doing that right
there is none of that going on you're
not to see a
china media calling out what president
xi is doing you're not going to wake up
in the morning again see a cnn or a fox
type of a situation it's not going to
happen there
it's not a kind of a situation where
they're bashing each other you cannot do
that
like a cnn of the world calling out
trump or a fox of the world calling out
obama that's not going to happen in
china
on the media side but that's everything
because that's everything so they say
listen you want to do business go ahead
do business as long as as long as you
don't disrespect and you do what
we do to do okay the culture so how does
the cap
yeah it's like the mob but so but how
does that hinder
you know entrepreneurship capitalism you
know free spirit
well what hinders what happens there
okay so give me the dna of an
entrepreneur
i mean everything we talk about every
single day toughness grit sticking it
out work ethic
principles mma of an entrepreneur is
what i think i can do it
better than the government so president
so so jack gives a speech about how he
thinks he can do it better and he talks
about lack of financial system
innovation must come at a price and
credit management
he thinks he can do it better is he
inspired for him to be a president is he
inspired politically for himself does he
want to kind of take the next step is he
kind of want to be the trump or he wants
to go out there and say
i want to go out is he a threat to
president president g because he's
speaking at a time where he can be
more world leader type of person where
he has
connection with china but he can also
speak english he's very eloquent where
he can be more a
global type of a power is he trying to
play a power play to take the next
position of
life for himself does he want that i
don't know i do know the way he started
it he says
my message is either immature incorrect
laughable and i'm semi-retired
a person who wants to be a president
probably wouldn't start a speech like
that yeah
immature incorrect laughable and i'm
semi-retired why would you not say that
he's got like those words is that no to
say if you think i'm a mature for saying
this
i i said i it may be immature so i'm
agreeing with you immature i may be
incorrect you're right i am incorrect
it may be laughable you're right i do
agree with you that i may be laughable
so
if you disagree please know that i'm
also in agreement with you
so to to button this up because i know
we need to probably move
tom laid out three very viable scenarios
right he's either dead
he's in uh hiding or he's in custody
what's your vote
i don't i don't know i honestly i i
could nobody knows yeah i
i don't think he's dead that's number
one so i take the debt out i don't think
he's dead
um i don't think uh even with all the
private airports and how to leave the
country
fast without somebody saying he's
leaving
if he left early before somebody coming
after him
because i don't know the speed of how
quickly this was related to the power
people if he's given a speech
somebody in there is sitting there
texting the right people that are
working directly with g to say here's
what he just said
and here's a recording somebody so 21
minutes i listened to them boom
call them i think if they wanted them
they'd be there so i couldn't tell you
i'd love to hear what the audience
thinks yeah jonathan lee reynoldso says
if give 10 bucks if china really killed
ma what will that do
to the future of unicorns other
countries need to market china
entrepreneurs
and offer them a safe haven you know i i
i
i don't disagree so i'm saying i don't
think that's the case
he may be in custody he may be hiding
probably more
probably more custody than hiding i
think it's more custody and revealing
the stuff that they have on him to bring
him back and train him for a few months
of how to sound and look like when he
gets on camera
maybe i think it's more training right
now re-education
like they have like the the uyghur yeah
it's like the muslims in china and the
mind
it's like when the mob went through this
week i interviewed a guy named um
jack falcon now jack falcone which was
fascinating he talked stories about greg
de palma
the mob uh era he was an fbi agent
undercover 24 out of 26 years
where he was undercover no but i talked
to dr cyril wecht i don't know if you
know who dr cyril wecht is he's the
number one pathologist
award-winning pathologist for the last
six years he's done 21 000 autopsies
okay 21 000 and 41 000 he's monitored
and supervised 41 000 that he signed off
on
he held the elvis brain et yeah that's a
lot of dead body got some very very
good stories that we're talking about uh
you know
i i i don't i don't know i don't know
i don't know i don't i almost don't want
to say what i want to say here with this
but
what do you mean no no no no
yeah i don't i don't know uh oh you know
he has to surface at some point
and then the question is will he talk
will he give the back he doesn't have to
surface because
the guys the mob went to j edgar hoover
and said hey here's pictures of you
know you're a cross stretcher you're gay
hey shut up leave us alone don't say
anything anymore
jade groover went to kennedy and said
hey here's the pictures i got about
marilyn monroe okay so you got to stay
quiet
or else okay so that's like a regular
thing so
hey chinese ccp hey jackman this is what
we got on you moving forward
here's your script here's this we need
you to sign this up if you don't we're
going to ruin your life what do you want
to do
and we're going to train you for the
next couple months until you agree to
this i think that's what's going on he
could be a big piece of propaganda for
them right a big selling point i think
so
i think so tom hear the pictures i have
of you lauren sanchez uh i had your
30th birthday wrong i was an observer
that's it
[Laughter]
all right so what do we want to talk
about next i don't know but that's that
that's pretty interesting what's going
on with jack
ma that is that is a humongous story uh
global
georgia runoff okay georgia runoff is uh
taking place today yep georgia election
rule today
are you flying runoff races no candidate
exits 50
as republicans have 50 seats 48 two more
you know
etcetera etcetera you got two names that
are going off back and forth georgia has
not elected a democratic senator since
24 years is a long time
uh the runoff races come after president
joe biden made history as the first
democrat to win georgia's presidential
race since 1992
nbc news projected they're not even
calling president you know the
president-elect joe biden because it's
not
done yet you haven't collected your
money yet close to half a billion
dollars
close to half a billion dollars close to
half a billion dollars has been injected
into
two races as both parties race to secure
slim majority in the state
either to give life to the legislative
hope of a president-elect joe biden or
stamp them
out before his term begins
a record 3 million voters have already
casted their ballots in the elections
making up 38.8 percent of all registered
voters
in georgia thoughts you know
okay so it's been since 1997 since
georgia has elected a democratic senator
kai what were you saying as far as a
presidential 92 something like that
right
96 you know what okay the reason shifts
or
the reason trends like that shift is
when there's a dynamic person to vote
for
so there isn't one of those on the
democratic side in georgia right now in
the senate runoff election
so if a democratic candidate wins today
something's up i mean it's just that
simple uh when you collect
three million ballots in advance the
level
or the opportunity to do bad things with
those ballots is is high
and if you just if you just look at this
objectively stacy abrams
you know is a very very big figure in
georgia collect you know
getting votes collecting these ballots
early
there was a court case last week where
they tried to slow down some of this and
the judge said no
i will not slow it down that was stacy
abraham's sister
who was the judge so we all know what's
at stake with this today
um are are the democrats that
sure of themselves that you know
something fishy could happen again
and no one will find out i don't know i
just
i think for the sake of the country
whether a republican or democrat
it helps to have a little bit of balance
in power
and i think for the sake of the country
it's important that purdue
or loffler one of them wins today it's
that simple
and you know what it's going to get ugly
there's going to be violence no question
about it
you think there's going to be violence
fema actually came out homeland security
actually came out said last week you
know regardless of what happens there's
going to be violence in georgia
you know there is you know dc is bracing
for what's going to happen later this
week with the electoral college vote
in congress tomorrow so it's a volatile
time in our country
it's scary and you know what i i just i
hope one of those republican candidates
win for the sake of the country who do
you think has most uh uh
more likely to win you know i would have
said purdue probably but he's been in
quarantine since last thursday so he he
was he had some some contact with
somebody that tested positive for covet
so he hasn't been able to campaign
i don't think it matters i think your
mind has been made up a long time ago i
don't think you're going to switch your
mind
and and make your decision on who you're
going to vote for in the last three or
four days
uh i like lafayette i like kelly loffer
i really do
i mean you know her husband is the
president of what
new york's new york stock exchange like
i said yesterday she's got a pretty good
consolation prize she's married to a
billionaire even if she doesn't win
i i think one of them's going to win i
don't trust the polling and yesterday
the polling came out and said that it's
very very close
we learned back in november you know
what kind of stock we can put into these
polling
you know numbers so i think a
republican's going to win i think it'll
probably be loffler
yeah again i haven't really been paying
attention for the last couple weeks
obviously
we've known about this for two months
that this has been the target date since
everything
but it's gotten really ugly in georgia
what's the
the one thing i did see in the news
recently was trump made a call to the
republican
secretary of state of georgia trying to
find 11 000 votes the guy's like look
dude
like i'm a supporter of you but i'm not
about to do anything
and plus he recorded the conversation
yeah so i think uh
carl bernstein who was one of the
watergate writers
uh was like yeah this is straight up
worse than watergate like
what are we talking about here he's
calling you know trump has a way of
talking where he's like
look i don't know i'm not telling you
that you should find this but maybe you
can do this
like a very mafia kind of talking right
very interesting what happens there but
back to you where again i haven't been
following
the the news last time i think we spoke
you were at 30
trump was still going to win where are
you at right now
30. you're still there yes damn 30
man okay so at what point are you down
to zero like when biden like
when biden steps into office no when he
wheels his walker into the oval office
but
at that point you'll say all right like
he's the president like i just wanna
yes i'm being genuine here yes okay yeah
it's not official yet
okay 30 but you're still at 30. yes
where do you think most trump supporters
are at this point
i'm asking legitimate questions here
where are trump supporters there
are they do they still think that he's a
true true true truth yeah that's what
i'm asking oh i think they're thinking
this thing still has a chance they still
do a hundred percent i think a lot
gotcha i'm not saying they think it's a
hundred percent yeah
but i think trump supporters believe
there is a chance that this thing could
stop
one of my best friends is like the i
have actually a lot of best friends who
are very close friends who are huge
trump supporters
and they're constantly texting me like
the one guy that ty you spoke with um
joe he's like oh it's happening bro it's
it like he'll
randomly it's happening everything i've
been talking about happening i'm like
what's happening tell me something like
you know what i think a lot of those
like your friend yeah trump's been too
quiet for the last three weeks
what well i mean other than the call to
the secretary's database other than you
know that whole watergate called
he's played a lot of golf he's but it
makes you think
he has something up his sleeve he don't
got nothing up his lead player
i'm not saying it's going to work i just
think something's up is what's your
number at this point
i mean tom's somehow trump lost
the election and tom's numbers have gone
on but i'm also saying 70
chance that biden is gonna be the
president yeah but you were at 20
or like 15 like two months ago yeah so
but you were at five percent this entire
time are you still there
five percent okay so you know what fi
again i explain to you what five percent
to me is
yeah five percent to me is i'm not gonna
make the bet
on five percent i'm telling you there's
a five percent chance because you don't
know what's going to happen all of a
sudden something could flip
pazzazzi morano just sent a five dollars
and said i hope the democrats win in
georgia so they can rewrite the
constitution with gender neutral
pronouns
amen and a woman i heard some guy say
that yeah
so but this is a very big day in georgia
like whether kelly leffler or rafael
warnock win
versus david perdue john ossoff um
[Music]
what i'm finding comfort in is the fact
that the people running georgia are
republicans what brian kemp is the
governor of georgia
mm-hmm republican huge trump supporter
trump is like threatening to throw him
in jail because he won't
listen then you got a what is it
roefesberger or whatever the uh the
secretary of state is
that that was the guy on the call that
was like oh with all due respect mr
president like
you're lost homie like i don't know how
to tell you this but
but trump's like no maybe i didn't lose
he's like yeah
you did sorry you know it's awkward
these phones yeah but that conversation
happens with every presidential
candidate i guarantee you bill clinton
was leaning on people obama leaned on
people
just like every other president hey can
you find me 11 000 votes oh you think
that's like a thing that everyone does
totally
oh i totally do i if you're in politics
you're doing that all right so
here's another question let's say they
find these 11 000 votes oh
that was he's like 5 000 dead people
voted right uh
roethlisberger he's like yeah two
which just goes to show you that he's
full of crap because there's way
more than two votes i'm just recapping
the conversation none of this is my
opinion okay it's for all the
soy boy haters out there shout out to
the show by mafia
um the um i'm just i i heard that
conversation
but um
it's it's interesting to see what's
going to happen here i feel like you got
something to say how does he turn
on his own how does a how does a
republican secretary of state hand this
over to the lawyers they believe in
america not
just trump is my assumption i think no i
i disagree
i think there's a part of it where um
they believe in needing their income and
keeping their jobs
you're going there with it it's a very
logical assessment
if you're not emotionally connected to
trump you care about your job
the person that to me it's kind of like
very interesting why he's such a true
believer and he's putting his reputation
on the line is ted cruz
that's the one that's very interesting
to me because he's going out there being
no this is not real he did not lose we
did not lose the election right
he's not backing down and he's going to
stand up very easy answer what is that
i mean and same with josh hall what is
that uh where's josh hawley missouri
where are we yeah the whole antifa came
to my house yesterday
it's a very easy answer what is it
inspiration to be president 100
okay in 2024 does he want to be having
trump base being like yeah
ted cruz stuck with us and he was there
when we tried to steal the vote and we
we love you ted
yeah or like well he was honoring
democracy let me ask you a question let
me ask you a question
there is also part of that that he's
taking a bigger risk
the bigger risk is the fact that when
that happens later on
you're you're assuming that all the
republicans are going to be for cruz
and all of trump's is going to win the
election in 2024
if cruz decides to run for president
2024. so there is
a risk for cruz as well there i'm just
surprised that he's doing it it's risk
and reward right i think
i think we're talking about ted cruz now
we're i mean it's gonna which by the way
the base is what you wanna say about ted
cruz ted cruz gotta be one of the
smartest guys that you got in america
he's the
genius the guy is yeah i don't care what
anybody says that guy's a genius i'm a
fan
you know and i wonder what his
aspirations are i don't know if they are
president you know there's people what
do you mean
he ran for president in 2016 clearly
there's also talking about
him being in the supreme court i mean
there's a lifelong job that you don't
have to campaign for
right so um who knows he could be a
supreme court i saw that conversation
come up about being
him being a supreme court the reality of
it is exciting he's not going away
he's not going away yeah he's he's not
going away in the fact that he has
trump's back that kind of surprised me a
little bit by the way did you see the
gallup most admired man of the year
who was it who do you think obama
uh trump was
ranked as the most admired man of the
year 2020.
congratulations donald trump great job
now here's a it's a question for you
there's a question for you because
i know would you say gallup is a
left-leaning or a right-leaning
organization if you were to just gallop
yellow probably center left i would
assume
where would you put gallop far left far
left really yeah maybe let's just
give me some give you some data on why
this is so ridiculous that they came up
with this
so history of the most admired
men of all time okay last year i'll just
give you last year
trump was this year the year before was
trump and obama
a tie last year 2019 they tied best
friends
so for men most admired man of all time
is eisenhower 12 times obama 12 times
reagan eight times clinton eight times
two republicans two democrats okay
bush seven times republican johnson
lyndon four times democrat nixon
four times george h.w bush four times
macarthur
three times carter three times kissinger
non-president three times john f kennedy
three
uh uh two truman two trump two
john pope john paul the second
very favorite yeah it's one time okay
but what do you mean one
uh of the year yeah of the year how are
people
winning it that's like oh it's like 100
years right you could win it five years
in a row you could win it ten years in
order
you said you said obama won it twelve
times time how's that even possible
actually yeah like two years ago his
numbers don't work
if you want to know obama started
winning the most admired man since 2008
eight nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
19.
12 times it's that he's won it even when
he was out of office
now the yeah admired women who do you
think is at the top
and it's not even a close race hillary
clinton it's not even a close race
is it michelle or is it hillary who do
you think is at the top hillary michelle
oprah winfrey hello
number one oprah but oprah's never
wanted once that was a trick question
oh my god he got me so watch this
hillary clinton
120 125 times 22
times hillary clinton these numbers
don't make sense eleanor roosevelt 13
thatcher six jackie kennedy five mother
teresa four nancy reagan four rosalind
rosalind
carter three times golda mere three time
michelle obama three betty four two
barbara bush two
mammy eisenhower two pat nixon laura
bush ethel kennedy
elizabeth kenny all one but hillary
clinton
has been the most admired woman
from 2002 all the way down to 2017 until
michelle obama you know what's crazy
every year every year this is such a
surprise
that's your community pelosi isn't on
the list yeah
hey you know what's crazy about this
that's a good point hillary clinton
has been the most admired woman in the
world 22 times
she's not even in the top 10 in her own
house as far as
[Laughter]
i don't 22 times makes notes and trump's
made it on that list one time
trump's made it one uh two times now
what do you think about that eric i know
you're excited about hillary
clinton 22 times thank you it carries as
much weight as people magazine's sexiest
man of the year right
i mean i don't know i'm surprised the
rock isn't number one
he's probably working his way most of my
most famous would probably be the rock
he
they say 57 percent of the world
recognizes his face
he's the most recognizable face wow
number one
more than obama oh yeah he's number one
more than trump hey do you guys remember
the rock when he was a wrestler
do you remember how yeah yeah yeah we do
tom yeah no but i mean for real like did
you
watch wrestling he was the funniest yeah
but i mean like really do you see this
guy
i wrestling i would love to see part of
that persona come out
god he was so dead what do you mean by
part of that persona oh just the trash
talking the character the
the thing that he used to do with coach
remember the the announcer
for the wwe uh he was just so you
couldn't watch that
and not think he's going to be the
biggest movie star in the world
but you know what he's a tactician
there's a bigger end game for him i
think you think he's going to run for
president eventually don't you
who the rock yeah yeah if there is
if i could bet on him running not him
winning if i could bet on him running
i'd put a million dollars on her right
now and it almost if i could bet on him
right sure
and it's almost like his his stance
would be i'm doing this for america i
have to do this i have no choice but to
run
you know and i i think there's a very
good chance too because where are you
where are you you know what he could
start with he could start with governor
of california when we get newsome out by
the end of the year i think that's too
boring
i know it is i think that's too boring
for you i don't think he's excited
president or bust huh
being a governor is boring oh so so it's
very important jazz blast just gave 25
bucks
and he said i pledge twenty five dollars
for adam to purchase some uh
some depends adult diapers for january
20th he will crap his pants trump 20 24
more years
so yeah so that's my point these people
right here whoever this guy is but he
gave you 25 bucks thank you i don't see
any of that
um he is so far-fetched in lunacy world
that he's giving money
to project whatever ridiculousness he's
thinking but that
i want to hear those opinions because
it's like he actually believes so what
do you want to ask him so you want to
ask him okay so let me ask get him on
the phone let's get him
why do you believe for a fact that
matter of fact if you're in the states
if you're in the states send your phone
number let's call them
look at this game set up are we ready
for it i want to know why they're so
ready what was he so sure of send your
name like you're thirty percent
and you lose one zero three four zero
one one three two like you love trump
and you're at 30 percent guys
four zero one one three two adam wants
to talk to you
i just want to know why if you talk over
me he doesn't get the number
text your phone number three one zero
three four zero one one three two i
don't
care about vaz i care about the you said
vaseline's out there that are all gonna
talk to the guy that's getting bad there
he is who is this good job baz
way to go basketball see what he got
okay there's nothing wrong with being a
believer
no i have no problem with you loving
trump and being a believer
i have no problem with tom's ridiculous
stuff it's the hundred percenters out
here
it's the hundred percenters who still
believe that trump's going to win
and he that it was stolen and there's no
doubt and
meanwhile he lost by seven million votes
and the electoral college wasn't even
close same
amount of i just want to know why why is
it a hundred why is it
well maybe it's 90 like how is it still
possibly 100 in your mind hey have you
guys i want to hear what
have you guys noticed that dominion is
going after people that have been saying
that there's fraud and trying to sue
them
you got his number or no
he's at work get a life vaz quit your
job and get on the podcast buddy good
job get a life
thanks for watching yes he's out working
listening to it
while at work brilliant okay all right
so so
so uh uh north korea request covet 19
vaccines from global group
country which has reported zero
infections has also asked several
european embassies
how would my obtain the shots according
to the familiar p to p
uh people familiar with the matter in
recent weeks north korea has reached out
to
north korea hasn't reached a single kova
19 case
the kim yong-un regime has called
combating the virus
a matter of national survival has sealed
off its borders and suspended
the foreign travel last week state media
warned
of the new variant of the coronavirus
urging citizens to be on maximum alert
nearly 12 000 people have been tested
for kobe 19 in north korea through
december 17th with tens of thousands
have been quarantined according to the
world health organization health experts
and foreign officials are skeptical that
north korea is virus free
they have zero cases
none zero hot the hot next aren't where
is north korea located
like right next to china nothing but
they're saying zero yeah
i mean obviously kim jong-un you gotta
believe you know if he says it it's
probably true right
i think if you're reading between the
lines here they have a huge problem with
it probably
you know if they're asking for it they
can't admit to anything and it's it's
not like
he's going to win humanitarian of the
year anytime you don't think he'll win
only in this country in north carolina
north korea but yeah this
this thing touches every part of the
globe including antarctica by the way i
guess people have tested positive up
there so penguins and you can imagine
how fast it would it would travel there
they won't let any information out now
they're going to have access the other
interesting thing to watch is this
chinese
version of the vaccine there's like two
or three coming out of china that isn't
tested
to the level that the american
vaccinations are and i'm sure they'll
have plenty of access to that but
no i'm sure they have a huge problem
with covet i mean
north korea the the the lies and the
misinformation that north korea puts out
there even just about kim jong-un i
think there's rumors that
he's never gone to the bathroom he
doesn't need to use the bathroom or
something like that
something crazy i mean i'm wearing adult
diapers over here this
guy never even uses the freaking
backpack although he does kind of look
like he hasn't gone through
exactly yeah exactly so it's believable
yeah so it's interesting this
like the you know what's the story with
like when you lie
you got to remember all your lies then
you got to kind of keep up with the lies
and then we've got zero infections but
like we really
need some help over here it's it's kind
of hard to keep maybe dennis rodman will
fly a humanitarian mission into north
korea with
covet vaccine for everybody gotta love
this stuff because when you get into
situations like this and you get caught
like this it's so embarrassing
it's so embarrassing when you get caught
like this by the way china warns of
retaliation for
new york stock exchange the listing of
companies
which was three companies china telecom
china mobile and china
china unicom they said saturday they
would take necessary counter measures in
response to the new york stock exchange
announcement that it will de-list three
major chinese
telecoms and the latest flare-up of
tensions between beijing and washington
the stock exchange said thursday that it
would de-list china comp china telecom
china mobile and china unicorn hong kong
ltd with trade of companies
the move stems from an executive order
president trump issued november 12
bearing
investments in publicly traded companies
that the u.s government says are owned
or controlled by the chinese military
china opposes the americans from abusing
national security by
listing chinese companies into so-called
commun communist china military
companies list and we'll take necessary
counter measures to resolutely safeguard
the legitimate rights and interests of
china
companies a spokesperson said however
however
what happened this morning something
changed tell us well
mission accomplished for them they were
right the new york stock exchange
just did an about face and they gave no
explanation to it they they said upon
further consultation so
clearly um it worked uh this benefits
china
i don't know who made the decision but
wow that's pretty scary there's going to
be consequences and then we immediately
bow down to them unbelievable
i think um you know
speaking of trump and what was the list
that he won gallup
gallup most admired um you know the
problem that i have with
with people is not being able to see the
positives even if you don't like
somebody
right so if you don't like trump there's
still positive things that he has done
if you don't like biden you think he's
old and senile there's still good that
can come from it so it's not
you know all negative or all positive
and i think one of the great things that
trump has definitely done
is made us very acutely aware of what
the
wtf is going on in china and the ccp and
and i know this was an executive order
and
apparently the new york stock exchange
can just reverse their decision that
they were going to play ball
but one thing that i will give trump
credit for is calling out everything
that's going on in china
whether someone like the new york stock
exchange will listen whoa oh
pat went down yeah go ahead um but
but clearly the new york stock exchange
sort of rebuked
trump's executive order or whether this
was the treasury department's
decision um but i i will give trump
credit on uh hot chocolate
you give trump credit so is that an
endorsement for trump yeah yeah
trump 2024 he's going to win 100 it's
not even uh here let me let me say this
on your point here adam
that'd be like saying hey this doctor
has really bad bedside manner but he
cured cancer
you know so i guess he did one thing
okay don't you think the problem with
china is big enough that it maybe could
have gotten trump reelected or should
have
i mean the fact that he has handled
china is not afraid to bow down to him
and what the repercussions of four years
of a president who will not
do that what that can mean to this
country my point is i think if you if
you respect what trump did
in regards to china i mean that's a big
deal i mean that should have been
something that maybe should have helped
him get elected well obviously it was
something that was on
the forefront of his agenda but if you
ask the average american what their top
three issues are i
guarantee you china is not in the top
three for most
americans the economy health care
covid what have you you know maybe china
term though
it will be long term right i mean this
is something that we can talk about here
one day it's gonna wake them up and
they're gonna be
realizing the power of china by the way
yesterday china
calls by biden's administration a new
window of hope
for u.s relations that's what they said
by the way did you see where the biggest
parties on new year's eve were
maskless
got you all in check i got the head i
think i make you'll break your neck
huh uh yeah that's pretty
disgusting uh when you i mean masculist
parties in wuhan while i'm
masking partying it up in south beach
something's wrong can i tell you a
theory that i've heard in california
regarding you know the hospitalization
and everything that everybody's acting
like it's out of control i
and i this is from doctors and this is
people that know is
there are a lot of people in southern
california that don't have health
insurance
okay so their first thing they're going
to do they're going to treat the
hospital or the emergency room like they
would their primary care physician
so you're getting hospitals bombarded
right now
with people that aren't feeling well
thinking or might be having covet or
whatever but it's being bombarded
that's why these hospitals are full in
southern california
it's because you know people say that
again what are they doing
the people that don't have health
insurance that maybe you would go to
your primary care doctor if you have
some symptoms or if you're not feeling
well
there's a high percentage of people that
are treating the hospital
like their primary care physician which
is overloading them they're just showing
up at the emergency room yeah exactly
and filling them up
so janet yellen janet yellen which adam
you're a big fan of jenny yeah i think
jenna yellen is a credible source right
biden team defends yellen making
millions and speaking fees with big
corporations apparently she got paid
seven million dollars
as a speaker from wall street firms and
other corporations after leaving federal
reserve in 2018
7 million i think a million of it was
from citigroup alone that she gave what
five or six or seven speeches
janet yellen is among the preeminent
economic policy maker in the world today
since leaving a fed
after several decades in public service
she has spoken on at economic
conferences universities and
business groups and financial
institutions about her experiences her
experience and expertise
are the reason president-elect joe biden
wanted her on the team working for him
on behalf of the american people to help
us build back better
from uh the this economic crisis the
biden transmission
team spokesperson said in the statement
yellen delivered a total of 50 speeches
to companies
paying her fi seven million dollars do
you have a problem
i have no problem i don't even none
whatsoever and i will say this about
biden he has no benefit to put an idiot
in that position
okay he's not an idiot exactly so he's
not gonna go out of his way to put
someone stupid in there number two
one of the things you said pat decades
worth of public service
go make some money if you've worked for
the government in public service for a
couple years
and people want to pay you to speak go
make 10 million 20 million i don't care
and i guarantee you people on boast i
guarantee you steven mnuchin is going to
be doing this as soon as he leaves
office he's going to be given
high high dollar speeches and who
wouldn't do that man that is the
ultimate gravy train
if a corporation's going to pay you to
come in and do a speech because you have
some expertise
go for it i got no problem yeah i i i
appreciate your
your answer here you know who else does
this everyone
everyone who leaves office like you're
no longer
a government employee if someone says
hey janet yellen i know you've been
out of office or you know not the uh um
chairman of the fed for the you know
last three months how would you like to
give a speech for a million bucks to
citigroup okay like why would you not
so i guarantee you trump is gonna do
this i guarantee you mnuchin's gonna do
this
the clintons obviously did this barack
obama is doing it as we speak
yeah like and pat you can vouch for this
it's a hell of a lot easier than writing
a book
right go do a speech for an afternoon
yeah fly first class
leave your money i mean you write a book
you think you know
no when you no this is no problem but i
have no problem with this taking place
the the problem is going to be the
following here's where the problem's
going to be
the problem is going to be city paid a
million dollars if later on there comes
a situation where
city is being protected by yelling in
any possible way etc etc that's where
there could be a little bit of a
you know a tricky situation but uh you
know it doesn't bother me but it's out
in the open it's like if something
shitty happens it's like
you can you know follow
where i think like look you know this
might sound a little
you know one percenter but it's seven
million dollars it's not
700 million dollars it's not a billion
that's
you made a couple million bucks right i
think we'd have a problem if it was
seventy thousand dollars you think what
her
she made seventy thousand dollars would
be like oh my god they ever running the
fed and she can't draw more of a salary
yeah i'm glad we're all on the same page
no problem uh
we have a couple comments i wanna
respond to here one of them said
for all the people in the comm in the
comment section saying trump won can you
say
can you just say 99 percent trump law
soy boy gang jack ma ware okay so dam's
life is on your side that's great we
have
a sober community what do you think
about jack moss supposed absence from
public oh we already talked about that
come back to the podcast
it was at about hour and five minutes
you'll be able to see it i agree with
vaz blast this guy gave 10 bucks moche
dc
but i'm giving a 50 chance uh
of trump remaining for another four
years we're gonna see the next couple of
days is going to be very interesting
what happens
tsa screened over 1.3 million passengers
on sunday
most since startup pandemic more than
3.3 million americans were screened over
the holiday weekend
the transportation security
administration tsa
you know it was the biggest sunday you
know biggest travel day
10 months you know standstill
um you know it's a far cry
from the two point four two two people
that were screened a year ago
but i tell you one point three kai can
you pull up the tsa
uh the numbers what do you think about
this thing going to point to these two
seven
i mean i think it's obviously a holiday
season flight it's more
uh full when you're traveling my flight
here from miami yesterday was packed
to dallas 100 i mean time flies every
week or so
right so like you're yeah i mean you're
you fly more than the airport's dead but
dallas is a popular route so i think you
got a lot of people come here because
it's a hub and then you're
anywhere else but the airports are dead
and i'll just say that dallas airport
lax is dead
you know i think this is great the more
the merry i think this is saying that
people are making decisions for
themselves
you know the number of covet cases are
up but i mean that doesn't mean
everybody
has symptoms or is sick or is dying from
it so
hey at some point we have to resume some
sort of normalcy in this country
the sooner the better go to cases and
death go to cases and
that's to see what those numbers are
looking like well i'll tell you what
people were partying for new year's like
there was no
pandemic going on whatsoever man it's so
dead
and actually one of the um interesting
places i was at in south beach shout out
to joya if you ever go down to south
beach
check this place out outdoor venue
amazing you pull up on your boat
i said to the owner uh my buddy marco i
said
dude everyone is here partying without a
mask like everyone what's up because we
were both in mass talking he goes yeah
they all had coveted throughout the
summer like they all of them they're all
here partying now they're
they're they're you know they're they've
had they all had kobe they all had covet
yeah over the summer this is the people
in the world now they're partying now
their partners have already had it
they already had it what do you call
that hurt immunity
yeah it's called hurt immunity and at
first when the herd immunity concept
came out what did everybody say oh my
gosh how dare you this is the
but now people are buying into the
concept of hurt immunity you know people
say no he's already had it well i don't
know i don't know if like they're
thinking
hurt immunity i think in they're just
thinking all right i already had it i'm
not gonna get it again
that's part of it it's eventually you
just have to know that eventually you
could get it
you know if you're healthy young doesn't
don't have asthma issues you're going to
be safe
and the percentage is right now death is
the lowest we've ever seen it so people
are sitting around saying okay
it's not as deadly as we thought it was
going to be well i think listen
and we don't need to go on a whole
diatribe about covid i think you know
the game has changed when this started
out in in march
and they didn't really know what was
happening and
even fauci was like oh you don't need to
wear a face cases
fluke cases 20 20 20 20 19. like i think
at first like in any pandemic people
start to panic what do i do am i done
am i gonna die i think people as we
clearly know here in this
office you get it and there's a 99.999
chance you're gonna you're gonna you're
gonna live you're gonna be okay you're
gonna you're gonna be all right
you might have a sore throat you might
lose some you know a couple week of work
or what have you right
but this is information that we didn't
know
six months ago when people were freaking
out so like when you hear something like
in la
they're shutting down outdoor dining
you're like what the [ __ ] is that
they're shutting down everything you
know it's big business for the media the
media is in business to scare the [ __ ]
out of people and that's all they do i
got so mad on new year's the la times is
the most
piece of crap worthless rag there is out
there before after midnight
um no this is before midnight yeah i
know tom
no the la times is so disappointing pat
you grew up reading the la times it was
a great
newspaper at one point that's thinking
about buying the l.a since their new
ownership it changes your pocket
i get alerts from the l.a times here's
one here's on new year's eve please
don't go out tonight
stay home with champagne and the remote
how to celebrate new year's eve with tv
who is the la times to tell me or
anybody else on this planet what to do
you just said not scarface right there i
mean seriously who is this
or the l.a me the audience any of them
not going
to party here's my biggest problem they
act like they care they don't get right
so here's my question buddy
did you stay in on that night there was
no place to go so you didn't go
so you listened to new york times i
didn't i'm talking about both sides of
your mouth
over to a friend i'm not gonna listen to
your new york times but let's stay in
shonda let's not do anything no no
believe me we
i would have gone out if there was a
place to go but we did go over to some
friends house hell yeah we did
hell yeah we went to our neighbors this
story is
very close to kai's heart so i had to
read the story because uh
washington yoga studio i know you were
going to use his religious exemptions to
avoid coronavirus orders gym and fitness
centers are not allowed to open until
january 11 of the cover 19 restrictions
the washington state yoga studio is
declining to comply
with state and local cronovirus pandemic
rules claiming it has religious
exemptions seattle's
hout yoga
one of the city's highest rated studios
is holding in-person classes despite
democratic governor jay inslee
recent extension of statewide
restrictions hot yoga founder
lee zakaria told newsweek she was not
asserting sessions
or religious religious gatherings but
said that she believes her work is
essential and is saving people's
lives however religious centers may
continue to function at 25
capacity or 200 people in king city with
implementation of proper social
distancing and face covering
creative or creativity this reminds me
of what you say all the time when we
talk about gyms like what the hell are
you talking about
people need to exercise people need to
people need to sweat
people need to be healthy so you hear
you have kai's favorite thing hot yoga
and uh you know they're using the
religious exemption i got no problem
with it just social distance six
six feet apart when you're doing your
stretching and your downward dogs go for
it
from number one that would be my message
to her number two be careful because
that washington
governor does not play have you seen
that story where they trip
don't play no they will personally go
after you and
try to destroy your life if they want to
but look it's going
we are getting very close for these
small businesses to be at
utter code red of desperation we're
going to see some crazy stuff happening
in the next few weeks and months and i
don't blame these people they have been
gutted they have been specifically
targeted and sold
and told by governors in this country we
don't care about you
we don't care what happens to you make
no money you're saying small businesses
yes
yes i'm saying that and i'm saying gyms
i'm saying restaurants it's so
unfair what they're doing to them with
no none no evidence
whatsoever this might be a nice uh
segway into what barstool sports is
doing to russia yeah exactly that's
exactly what i was looking at dave
portnoy raised 16.9
16.8 million dollars for 59 small
business owners and counting
and he launched the fundraising effort
with the non-profit
30-day fund for small businesses
impacted by kova 19 called the barstool
fund
last week and contributed 500 000 of his
own money
towards the effort do you have the video
ready kai or no if we have the video
just to kind of show uh what was said
it's it's uh it's great to see a guy
like that just going out there
supporting small businesses go ahead
dave just played 30 seconds of the
united states new york city
just shut down indoor dining it's like
how do you expect these people to
survive
how a restaurant is going to survive
they're already on their last legs and
you're pulling the plug look at the
sweaters the camera and the government
or at least they're not doing anything
acting like they care
no plan no relief no bailout
it's like what's going to happen so i
was renting raven about it marcus
lamoni's challenged me he's like why
don't you put your money where your
mouth is
well i've spent the last couple days
doing exactly that
so we're going to donate half a million
dollars and we've come up with a plan is
it the best plan no the best plan
is the government getting off their ass
and issuing relief
billions of dollars to these small
business owners
or losing their livelihoods and have no
recourse and no way to save it through
no fault of their own billions of
dollars
that's the solution that's the only
solution really but
barring that we're going to do what we
can it's the barstool fund
it is modeled around frankie bareille
you know frankie
all right frankie where we at frankie my
cameraman for the peace reviews
well his dad owns borelli's in long
island the
perfect example of the type of business
we're trying to save
throughout this pandemic i'm like hey
frankie how's your dad doing how's
borelli's doing
every month it gets a little bleaker um
so what this is 30 years old
single restaurant and they have no
indoor dining
so not only that but mr braley credit to
him who would never want to take a
handout in his life
also is still paying his employees he's
never shut off his payroll
so it's like i'm going down to the ship
i can't so by the way he kept calling
people facetiming him surprising him oh
my gosh
awesome man awesome we need more people
like this man for a fantastic job he did
what do you think about what he did here
with raising 16.9 million dollars with
59 different business owners
i think for the most part people want to
help i think people are looking for a
way to help out and i think good good
job portnoy i think that's amazing
you know he's ticked off at cnn because
cnn will not cover this story
that guy if you pull up something from
today he's going on a rampage about the
fact that
mainstream media is is ignoring
basically what he's doing
but i think it's phenomenal and hell he
i think they could do a telethon and
raise hundreds of millions because i do
think people
i want to help the people i want to do
something that i can to support small
businesses where i live i don't want
them to go under
it is unfair what's happening to them so
good good job
have you seen i mean all on his
instagram it's
for his last 20 or so posts and i
checked it
uh i don't know a handful of days ago so
i'm surprised this guy does he just
randomly or facetime the owner of a of a
bar
of a restaurant wherever all over the
world not sorry all over the country
california indiana ohio new york texas
and he says hey and they
like we did this obviously with
valuetainment it reminded me of that
and someone picked something oh damn
what's up bbd oh
damn you know it's awesome when you see
that genuine reaction
question is he randomly picking them or
are they asking for help are they
reaching they give a video
that says hey dave okay like hey
barstool i hope you see this
here's what's going on and then they'll
play that clip
and then dave responding like oh damn
what's up like
i think you know the reason we're
calling like it's it's awesome yeah
something that we can
you know kudos man for sure more more
power to him do you know who he was the
last uh week or so
partying itself was it really yeah yeah
i ran in you know
you ran into him yeah same place yeah
this place called swan
in south beach yeah he was there table
him five girls
that's it him five yeah there it is
yeah straight up the guy have you ever
seen but there were other people there
obviously
tyga the rapper was there and uh shout
out to the uh
the um groot hospitality group that
throw the party at swan but yeah
um we have to live vicariously through
adam yeah we do
what were you doing drinking in a bar i
was i was
i was drinking at a bar and i was uh
that's the american way
i had my mask on i would use a straw i
would sip and then
seriously no i mean i can actually see
you going with a mass toolbar did you
really have a mask on at the bar
you have to show up with a mask and then
when you go in here like just at any
restaurant then if it's
got it i look yeah most people that were
partying out there no mask
no no nothing whatever a lot of it was
outdoors
that's the difference in in miami you go
to in south florida
70 and gorgeous right now in january
right
knock on wood everybody but if you're in
new york
like there's no outdoor dining there's
no nothing yeah so there's people flying
down
to to get the good life in but uh and
he's one of them
you got more people that are putting
money here saying uh uh
joseph kohl's five bucks i'm a 99 i'm
i'm at 99.9
trump winning the only thing that will
keep him out is dems ignoring the fraud
and voting biden in to spite the
republicans
and then you have e-s-n-s headquarters
11-208
john gulf boulevard omaha nebraska
machine voting systems counts for 90
of our voting who is john galt five
bucks tate roberts
and we had another person here says what
do you think about trump's lawyer lynn
wood
tweeting chief justice roberts as a
pedophile and epstein's still alive it
will be released january 6th in dc
that's by gtr8523
and then uh joe gauss godess i'm
commissioned my company public
originalizer
my company hires extra workers for more
revenue starvers workers high turnover
how can i help okay cool there you go
and then thoughts on protest tomorrow
and uh uh today and tomorrow who's the
person that wrote that
the last one yeah i have no clue who it
is
thoughts on the protest today oh that's
from silly white boy
silly white boy thoughts on philly white
boy that guy
today and tomorrow in dc my my question
for the guy who said 99
are these people acting emotionally
or logically 99.9
that he's still gonna win that this is
i mean yeah is that emotional or logical
99.9 percent
come on man what is that 99.9 there's
going to be fireworks tomorrow
because it all goes down you know but
they have to validate the electronics
hasn't it already gone down no
tomorrow's a big day i'm not saying that
anything tomorrow versus like everything
like
the electoral college has voted they've
already done this tomorrow they have to
validate the vote of the electoral
college and then if you want to oppose
it you have the opportunity to join
session tomorrow uh the house and senate
are together tomorrow's a big deal and
there's hundreds of people that are
going to already say
republicans have already said that
they're going to object to this so there
will be fireworks and
you know what and the fact is they're
mobilizing in dc already for why
let me ask you since we're on this topic
uh again haven't been following the news
last couple weeks yada yada
he hasn't won any or very little of the
court case i think he's like one for 50.
yeah what like if he was like 10 for
20 or 10 for 50 all right but like oh
for 50
one for 50. that's not a great sign what
what is it
what is that how are you still at 99 or
like that's that's what i'm grappling
with like if there was
like i want all the evidence to come out
if there was legitimate fraud get it out
there no one wants an illegitimate
situation going on here in america that
would never happen
but that would never happen what that
what would the right all the legitimate
fraud would never show up
that'll never show up you think
everything every fraud can be found
not everybody i'm saying in the court
cases you don't have to bring it you
don't think crimes get away criminals
get away with
all the freaking time you don't think
voter fraud can vote fraud the folks who
worked on the inside can get away with
voter fraud
you don't think people who are
controlled by district leaders where
the district leaders are supporting them
you think they don't dictate the results
of a criminal getting away with
something
you don't you don't think when somebody
all of a sudden who's a criminal did
some crime somebody can come and pardon
them but they're still a criminal
you don't think these types of things
happen happens all the time so i don't
think we're going to find out the truth
there's no way in the world 100 the
truth you're not going to find out
you know it's it's not something we're
going to find out not today not tomorrow
i don't think it's going to happen
i think maybe 30 years from now some
people are going to come out maybe 10
years from now some people are going to
come out
just like for three years everybody
talked about russia and then guess what
oh it was a uh dossier paid for hillary
it's not really real nothing really
happened with russia
okay so let's talk about something else
you know so what's going on over here
you know so
it's not going to happen you know trump
has access to any type of information he
wants
from the intelligence agencies something
tells me that he always seems like he's
biting his tongue like he wants to say
more
like he knows he has proof this or that
i could see a scenario where he gets out
of office if he
you know if this doesn't work out for
him he does a pay-per-view where he
reveals everything he knows
could you imagine everybody it's very
interesting that you have this opinion
because i have the exact opposite
opinion i think this guy
says whatever he wants at any given time
this is how i know for sure that there's
never been aliens that we've caught in
america
because that guy would be blabbing about
all the secrets we've ever had are you
kidding me
i feel like trump thinks that i says it
well maybe this that i don't know i'm
thinking like
trump is exhibit a of why they're
everything's out there
i don't think he's holding anything back
i i'm dreading the next four years with
biden i mean i'm excited to not have to
wake up and think about
what did the president do today what did
he tweet today what's the drama today
i'm thinking
oh biden did nothing today awesome yeah
but wasn't it a nice
thing for the last four years knowing
there was no war there was no armed
conflict going on over
overseas you know there's something
because there's a lot of armed conflict
or wars under obama but you know
afghanistan was going on yeah that
happened under bush
well it was started under bush but it
was continued and it continued under
trump what do you mean no trump stopped
it
he he still going on dude i mean look
he i mean look whatever you say i'm just
gonna say i love trump
no not at all i'm saying i love the fact
that we're not at war
who loves war i don't want war it's like
man it's like your opinion man
somebody asked a question about iran you
guys heard about iran and you're right i
want to get pat's opinion on this so
please let's talk about enriching
uranium to
20 purity we got uh five more minutes on
this year
tehran returns to pre-nuclear deal
levels of uranium enrichment the nuclear
activity
which returns iran to an enrichment
level at its uh at last
reached before entering the
international core dials up pressure on
washington across the red line
set by european countries that remained
committed
to the agreement after the trump
administration withdrew from it in 2018
the move
threatens to complicate president-elect
joe biden's plan to rejoin the deal that
place limits on tehran's nuclear program
but which floundered
after the u.s left it and reimposed
crippling economic sanctions on tehran
mr biden has said the u.s would join
rejoin the deal as long as iran complies
with the terms the enrichment activity
also raises tensions in the middle
east which when the region is already on
edge during the warning
days of trump administration
iran nuclear iranian forces sees a south
korea flagship on monday according to
semi-official iranian news agency
heightening tensions with the u.s
ally forces brought boarded the vessel
because it was
creating unspecified pollution the
persian gulf the agency said the vessel
owner dm shipping of busan south korea
didn't respond to calls what do you
think what's going on right now with
this oil i i want to get your opinion
more than
more than tom and i's this is something
i think right in your wheelhouse i know
a couple episodes ago
you kind of enlightened us on the what
the pros and cons are where a lot of
cons on the iran
pay for play all right stop do this just
get it
off basic iran historically uh
uh uh anybody in iran who
okay so politically think about it this
way i showed a chart which i can't do it
here but i'll just show it to you this
way
okay if there is a
a republican president okay or
democratic president the democratic
president republican leader
you have a democratic president there
republican leaders so
if if the leader is republican in iran
okay they fear dems okay
so the shah republican right
conservative he fears
a carter okay if the the
country is hardcore right now where
it's hezbollah's you know don't bother
don't do any of that stuff and they're
not pro-america they're not westerners
they don't believe in
the freedom of speech type of deal where
the shot wanted to give all these
freedoms to people
you don't need to put on you know your
uh uh
job you don't have to do all this stuff
you're free woman can do this woman
don't have to
marry at 13. you want to increase the
age you have more voice you have to do
this
okay the left kind of didn't like that
and then on the other side if it's
hardcore hardcore controls
they don't like republicans because
republicans want to give you more
freedom
they want people to have freedom of
speech they want people to have freedoms
but when it's hardcore
hardcore like this they kind of like
democrats because they don't fear
democrats
because democrats just want to say
listen it's okay let's just make it work
it's not a big deal what can we give you
for you not to be
you know we'll make you happy so biting
they're so
happy about president-elect joe biden
iran the current regime of iran is so
happy
about biden and when biden comes back
into power let you come
comes into power when this thing takes
place whatever the chances are
everybody's talking about thirty percent
five percent
ninety nine point nine percent zero
percent when this thing happens and
biden's there
you know the deal is going to come up
there's no question about it
the deal is gonna come up there's no
question about it they're gonna go out
there to
rebuild and even more than that
do you really think whether they have
the money or not you think they're gonna
listen to anybody my biggest thing has
always been accountability how do you
hold those guys accountable they don't
they're not gonna
they don't sit there and say we're not
gonna do what you tell us to do we can
do whatever we want to do that's their
mentality you don't tell us what to do
they'll take your money gladly and turn
around and say death upon america
they don't look at america as a partner
they look at america in a different way
but in this situation here this is their
way of saying we're already going back
into it
and if you don't give us the money
here's what we're going to do so it's a
way of saying hey bud and prepare
yourself because you're about to have
a hostage situation exactly what it is
so um
this 20 purity and i'm no nuclear
scientist you know breaking news here
what does that mean what happens when it
gets to 30 percent
50 80 percent what like i think we can
always
we don't know having a nuclear yeah
scientist
you know i i decided to go into
insurance after nuclear plants that we
had all over bring us back to your roots
pat when you were a
iranian scientist here's the percentage
you have to worry about if
iran gets a nuclear weapon there's a 100
chance they probably use it
that's why you have to do whatever you
can to make sure they don't get it but
even if they do use it does that
not automatically mean that they are
wiped off the planet because israel will
use it on them the united states will
use it on them saudi arabia will you
know whatever they'll do so
it's the same reason north korea is not
using it right like north korea you
send a missile you you no longer exist
so doesn't that no where does that
factor into the hostage situation and
they they do what they want to do hey do
you think do you think biden's going to
get rid of all the sanctions on iran
because they they work
when you put sanctions on iran and you
cut their economy off you know it works
especially when you get the whole world
to persuasion
i think there's a 70 chance he does 30
chance that he does not natalia m says
miami doesn't claim adam
natalia i don't know nothing you don't
know nothing to tell you message him on
instagram and tell him that to his face
yeah right to my face natalia natalia
okay so this is episode number 35 coming
to an end so thursday
we're doing a podcast right thursday
well we have thursday in the calendar
okay do we do yesterday
electoral college in congress tomorrow
it's going down on
thursday so thursday's going to be a
back
oh my god we should do a whole situation
oh oh
thursday's gonna be crazy
yeah at least i know that i went into
the wrong okay wrong goal no
it was the hot chocolate guys no not hot
chocolate but go ahead no i was gonna
say at least we know we're protected in
here right isn't that one time she said
there's like a secret stash somewhere
around here
just in case secret stash now you're
talking my language what do we got a
secret stash or what
did you have a secret statue in miami
when you were there no comment
you look good you really do like around
the sun you got
some sun got some other stuff done some
work he was on the boat he was on the
yacht yeah he was kicking it with it
chris had a good time good to be
i don't know i don't know if people know
about this but i think there's a
rumor that we're gonna have a nice time
in the next
few weeks month three years
five years ten years twenty years but
don't forget this guy was having the
time of his life also down there so
i've been in florida so many times on
the last month just on one day trips
just going back and forth trying to see
what's going on over there but yeah we
had a good time out there as well
um we had a good time out there as well
nice okay so everybody will be back
episode number three final thoughts this
is our first that's our first
show since the new year do we want to
spend the last minute or so
given some final you know new year's
thoughts going you did you did a great
um at the house in fort lauderdale i
believe you
gave a great uh segment about planning
before the end of the year and now the
new year is here
give us some final thoughts going into
this i i i am very very optimistic about
extremely optimistic about 2021 on all
levels
i'm just very optimistic about it uh i
think
uh uh the byte administration if they
take
and it's done with the one thing that
even the republicans don't have to worry
a lot about is
i said this last night to a group of
people that we were with i said there's
a difference between kennedy's
and trumps you don't tell trumps and
kennedys what to do
they tell you what to do so the people
of power don't like kennedy's and trump
there's two things you do with people
like that
you bring out as much dirt as possible
so don't get reelected or you eliminate
them
hence what happened with kennedy kennedy
and that was on second term so because
they were worried kennedy's were going
to be presidents for 16 years
first jfk no no no no john f kennedy
eight years
rfk eight years that's what they were
they eliminated yeah that's a scary
thought for the kennedys they would have
been running their mindset into all of
the country trumps are very similar to
kennedy's then you have different types
of
republicans that just come in there just
want to check mark hey i made it to the
top which is what being a president
and i'm a dem i made it to the top i
became a president but they are not the
kind that they impose fully their
beliefs on everybody but
because wall street backed them up so
you got the obamas the clintons the bush
so they backed them up here you're
funded you're president guys just don't
shake things up too much you'll get
elected twice
you know your legacy is going to be
cemented it's going to be all right but
here's what we need you to do
no elizabeth warren no bernie sanders no
aoc
squad no squad guess what wall street
shows
the cabinet it's that simple and biden's
not somebody that's imposing any of his
belief system
biden's just repeating what needs to be
said for him to get elected so i don't
think it's going to be as bad as
some of the republicans are going to
think the next four years tom last thing
how's
uh your friend joe biden's ankle
he probably broke the other one he did
it happened he's got two dogs right
it didn't it didn't get fixed that
dude's fragile that dude that's what
happens at 78.
that's what happens at 78. so having
said that again we'll see you again on
thursday in the next 48 hours take care
everybody
happy new year bye bye bye bye bye
you